okay so again we understand our purpose
we know ourselves what is our main goal
in this world and we constantly check in
inside inside this is very important
inner management in there engineering we
always see outside do outside but check
inside check in with your brain your
heart your gut how do you feel about
what you're doing and check in with
yourself more often about your purpose
your destiny and then you see how it can
be applicable to something like the
United Nations sustainable development
goals the biggest challenges on the
planet
how can your science become
translationally applicable to the
biggest challenges on the planet make a
list of your top 5 your top 10 your top
50 people that you want to get in touch
with in the field and do research about
what they're doing at the edge of their
field synthesize ask questions work on
our social skills build groups of people
that we can engage with on these
cutting-edge topics and share that
content around China in the world